hallo kinder ihr kennt ja mit sicherheit
dieses problem das hier ist die neue
youtube startseite und ihr habt
irgendwie alles auf der linken seite und
rechts habt ihr alles ganz weiß und nein
das ist kein schnee sondern dass es ganz
einfach weil youtube das irgendwie
komisch programmiert hat und da gibt es
einen kleinen trick den mir der
entertainment gezeigt hat und zwar gibt
es dort eine website namens user skript
org dort laden user wie zb in diesem
fall arzt lucky werden da ihre scripts
für bestimmte webseiten hoch das ist das
zum beispiel um die youtube startseite
ein wenig ansehnlicher zu machen und ein
wenig übersichtlicher
hier klickt einfach hier oben auf
install ich mache ich das einfach hier
schritt für schritt zeigen für google
chrome weil ich kenne das selber aus
tutorials dass das meistens nicht so gut
gezeigt wird machen wir hier in ordner
anzeigen sehen wir das hier ziehen wir
das hier über machen wir dies dann haben
wir das hier auf dem desktop diese diese
denkt datei so lang klicken wir hier
oben bei google chrome auf diese drei
striche gehen hier auf einstellungen
gehen auf erweiterung und ziehen das
hier einfach rein
dann klicken sie auf hinzufügen dann
wurde es nun hinzugefügt so dass können
wir schließen das können schließen
dann haben wir youtube und wenn ihr das
nun aktualisiert dann ist das in der
mitte das hier unten können wir auch weg
machen und ihr habt das nun jedenfalls
immer in der mitte und das ist auf jeden
fall deutlich angenehmer weil nun habt
ihr links und rechts nur ein bisschen
schnee anstatt einfach rechts den
kompletten schnee und links gar nix und
ja ich würde sagen ich hoffe euch hat
das geholfen der link zum skript es in
der beschreibung wir sehen sie den
nächsten videos freuen oder ein job